fireworks booths are now open for  business across the valley they only  sell fireworks though that are labeled  as safe and sane anything that leaves  the ground and shoots up into the air is  illegal if you're caught using those you  could face a really hefty fine if you'd  like to report illegal fireworks don't  call the emergency number 911 instead go  to i spyfireworks.com  and a quick refresher on fireworks  safety use the acronym wow it stands for  water one at a time and walk away you  should always have water on hand to  douse fires used for the fireworks  light fireworks one at a time never set  off multiple at once and make sure to  walk or run away once that fuse is lit  experts say the safest way to enjoy  fireworks though of course is to attend  a professional show and there are plenty